for our next talk I
welcome our next speaker
michael stewart and a talk it's about
learning your neural net for great good
please welcome Michael Stewart hello
everyone hope you all had a good lunch
so title of this talk is learn your
neural net
you know parenthetically for a great
good so Who am I so my name is stu alias
Michael Stewart
I'm a machine learning engineer at open
door in San Francisco so open door is a
context startup
you know we buy and sell homes online
and our mission is just to make the home
buying and selling process you know
radically simpler for you know Americans
everywhere so we have alpha offices here
in LA as well as in San Francisco and
Atlanta so if you're interested in
learning more definitely come and talk
to me afterwards cool so the goal of
this talk is to kind of puzzle through
the mechanics of of a neural net you
know here I heard a fully connected you
know like MLP a multiple layer
perceptron style neuron that on our way
to implementing one kind of be an inside
line style kind of compatible with the
the second a P I so what is a neural net
you know so who wikipedia the source of
all truth says that kernel net is kind
of a connect a collection of neurons
organized into layers and these these
layers are kind of connect connected by
synapses or weights that have parameters
that we kind of push up and down through
the learning process and typically these
these layers are connected through these
nonlinear functions that you know take
in inputs and spit out you know some
some floating-point number so that's
good but here you know this probably
easier to understand here is a here's a
graphic of one of these you know fully
connected neural nets basically you have
some input data over here we have you
know input data M you know with M
features it gets transformed through a
series of layers and in the end we make
a prediction you know maybe a number
maybe we're doing regression maybe it's
a classification question maybe we're
trying to predict
you know dogs and cats but whatever it
is you know the the kind of the basic
structure of these networks is that you
have a lot of data coming in and it kind
of becomes more refined over time until
we produce kind of a final output so
these artificial neurons they have edges
and they have these weights for these
edges that adjust as learning precedes
great but like how do we make learning
proceed that's kind of the crux of the
matter here so almost always the answer
is that we use gradient descent or some
some algorithm in there kind of the
gradient descent brought a gradient
descent family of algorithms so gradient
descent again you know we have Wikipedia
is gradient descent as an optimization
algorithm it's an iterative optimization
algorithm and it's used usually for
finding the minimum of a function in
order to take a step to take one of
these iterative steps what we do is we
find the gradient and we go in the
direction against the gradient so we go
down a hill and ingredient is just a
it's kind of a an abstraction of
derivatives so if I have a function y
equals x squared and I take the
derivative I'll get to X and a gradient
is kind of just a vector of partial
derivative information so if I have a
function of many variables instead of
just one you know for each variable that
I'm taking the derivative with respect
to kind of on the right hand side of the
equation you know that'll be like one
entry in my gradient vector so it's
really nothing more than just the
partial derivatives for a few different
variables or maybe just one for kind of
the the information encoded on the right
hand side of our equation ok cool so
we're gonna do a little did
initialization first not too important
and then this is the problem we're
trying to solve so this is kind of
famous the zuhr problem you know X or
problem where we have you know here's
simple like toy data and the first two
columns are of interest
you know this third column is actually
just noise it's junk and the first two
columns we see that you know our output
for the very first observation is 0 and
for the very last observation these are
kind of our targets these Y's are our
targets and in between we have all ones
so the middle for you know the middle
four rows we're trying to predict one
and the you know first and last row
we're trying to predict a0 and the
reason these middle four rows are one
is because again for these two these two
kind of initial columns you know we have
one or the other but not both
so that's XOR whereas for the first and
last row we have two ones and two zeros
so those would be zeros this problem is
it's kind of a little weird it's a
little wonky and it can't it's not
linearly separable so a technique like
logistic regression in the
classification setting wouldn't be able
to classify this because of this you
know nonlinear decision surface and you
know a infinitely complex neural net can
learn to approximate any function this
one will not be infinitely complex but
we will be able to approximate this
function because you know those
non-linear functions that the Wikipedia
definition spoke of you know these
non-linear functions these
nonlinearities allow us to approximate
even these nonlinear decision services
these initializations are for the
sigmoid function also known as the
logistic sigmoid function which is the
same function that's used by for example
logistic regression and is one of the
many quote-unquote activation functions
that you know neural networks may use
and we also have its derivative here you
know you know so a little calculus and
the derivative of the function will go
more into these functions in a little
bit so cool so we can initialize this
and then you know Zoar here here's kind
of the scikit-learn logistic regression
and it's not gonna get the right answer
so in particular we want you know 0 1 1
1 1 0 and we're not quite there yet so
for the sake of argument you know it's
true that there are a lot of you know a
lot of tricks up you know up by modelers
sleeves and we can make this linear you
know linearly separable so we know that
these first two columns are important
and you know if we take the sum over the
first axis for those do a little
trickery here and and then like modulo
that by to that kind of this kind of
returns the actual you know the way that
we set up why the you know this kind of
gives the answer so if we if we do a
little feature engineering then you know
we can get the right answer
so it's not that linear functions are
kind
like these helpless these helpless
models that you know have no hope you
know with a little feature engineering
they too can solve the sort problem but
the goal of this no network would be to
you know not need any human you know
intervention on this feature engineering
and to kind of learn these you know lean
learn these subtleties of the data on
its own so that's what we're kind of
striving for so that's good so what is
the easiest way we can kind of set up
this problem I would argue it's it's a
four loop you know we can try to make
one of these neural nets just proceed as
a as a standard Python for loop and see
what happens so you know that's that you
know got to start somewhere approach so
that's what we'll do so we're gonna use
the sigmoid function as our on
non-linearity it's this function here
you know 1 over 1 plus e to the negative
Z you know where Z is the input to the
sigmoid denoted by a sigma a Greek
lowercase Sigma and we're gonna do that
just because it's a familiar function
that some folks will know and it has
kind of a neat form so let's look at it
so you know one thing we can do is use
simpie so simple focus project so thanks
I'm focused so if we make some some
function here you know this this will be
a function that takes some some free
variable and returns you know returns
that that function we just saw this does
non-linearity and when we plot that
hopefully you know with the bit of luck
so just close that parentheses first and
with a bit of luck we'll see you know
here is the sigmoid function so the
sigmoid is a curve that kind of goes
from 0 to 1 in the you know in the
output domain you know so f of Q here
goes from 0 to 1 and you know it's it's
kind of rising quickly around 0 and then
it has these very flat tails you know
off to you know negative and positive
infinity
and we're also interested in the
derivative of this function and the
derivative looks like this so you know
the derivative is positive
right around zero and then rapidly tails
off it is you know very close to zero
everywhere else so that's kind of what
the the sigmoid function and the
derivative the sigmoid start look like
so with that you know let's dive in so
here we have a little data
initialization you know we have just
some these are our weights these are our
synapses or weights and we've
initialized them randomly
you know because gradient descent is an
iterative optimization algorithm this is
an exaggeration but it doesn't matter
where we start in practice it matters a
little bit but we can start randomly and
we'll still be able to proceed to the
correct answer through this kind of this
iterative four loop update step so if we
take these kind of these random betas
you know what we want to do you know in
the end is take these betas and update
them using the gradient information
right so we want to LR is all learning
rate you know it's a it's a it's a
parameter that we control and what we
want to do is kind of subtract the
learning rate times the gradient of
course we haven't defined these
gradients yet but you know minor
technicality so we actually have kind of
two hidden layers here so you know we
need more layers and what we're gonna do
is pass them through the sigmoid
function so we have this sigmoid
function we're just looking at and you
know we want to take the previous layer
basically the previous layer and
multiply that by by the weights to get
to the next layer so we're going to do
that two times basically and this is
what's called the forward pass of our
model you know so forward pass of the NN
and basically we start with some input
you know do this kind of this x weights
put it through a non-linearity and we
can do that you know an arbitrary number
of times here just two and this thing
right like this is our Y hat you know
this is our hypothesis so when you've
done the full kind of forward pass where
we do this you know non-linearity x
weights non-linearity the ending result
of that is kind of our hypothesis this
is you know what we're trying to we're
trying to have this spit out the correct
you know zero one one one one zero for
the for the
training data that we were looking at in
particular though this will actually
spit out probabilities not you know zero
on one classifications it will spit out
you know a number really close to zero
if it thinks the number of zero and
number really close to one if it sinks
thinks the the answer is one because
that's kind of how we posed the problem
so we have this forward pass but we need
a backward pass - so what's the backward
pass
well it certainly includes updating you
know updating the weights so you know
this is kind of the crux crux of the the
neural net is you know these gradient
updates but in order to get there we
actually need these you know grad zero 1
grad 1 to where those coming from you
know we don't we don't actually have
those yet so some of this will seem a
little mysterious but we're about to go
over some of the mystery on the next
slide so what's the loss well this isn't
mysterious at all you know we say like
this is the hypothesis for the
hypothesis for our network and we're
trying to figure out the loss of the
last layer is so basically the layer
that is supposed to predict you know 0 1
1 1 0 the loss of that is just like how
much did we miss by so our hypothesis is
layer 2 and the true answer is layer is
you know why so that's our loss you know
that that's pretty straightforward so
great so we had this lost term and now
this may look a little wonky but you
know we have this loss and we have this
like sigmoid prime this is the
derivative of our sigmoid function which
we're looking at before and we can just
you know put layer 2 through there and
then in order to get you know the
gradient for that kind of those those
weights those synapses from layer 1 to
layer 2 what we can do is take you know
this this layer 2 Delta and well what
else do we have you know we have this
layer 1 I can transpose that you know
multiplied by Delta I understand this
this may not make a staggering amount of
sense at this point but we're about to
review so that's one thing we can do and
you know we can kind of repeat that so
we have this this next layer and we're
gonna need to take care of it - this is
probably the downside of you know having
all your neural nets be for loops you
know a lot of copy and pasting it's
probably not not what our final solution
will look like but you know now we have
kind of the same setup but here we don't
we're not as lucky so here you know this
is like output layer
you know loss is easy you know it's
really easy to figure out what the loss
of the output layer is but it's not as
easy for these inner layers however you
know we're lucky you know we have this
this layer to Delta and it turns out you
know we have these betas and we can
transpose them and that might do what we
want so if we take a look at this you
know we're getting a number really close
to zero for numbers really close to one
and a number really close to zero so
that's good that's great you know if we
recall what why it looks like that's
exactly what I looked like so somehow
someway you know this like magic magic
calculus stuff going on here seems to be
on to something
so man you know let's let's figure out
what this magic calculus is doing so why
is this so like why why is this a
reasonable strategy well like what why
why is this the kind of the underlying
architecture for all neural networks
these days well the answer is the chain
rule which you'll hear kind of referred
to sort of interchangeably as back
propagation in the context of neural
nets and the chain rule is from kind of
high school calculus and what we have is
a cost function and you know our cost
function is a function of something and
this is something this here this is our
Y hat you know this is a hypothesis so
if we go backwards you know this this
this little ampersand is really it's
really a function so we could we could
call this Z you know some function and
close some parentheses and say well what
Z so so Z is really you know NP Matt
mole its matrix multiplication so this
two works and now we can see you know we
have sigmoid of Z here it's just a
multiplication times you know something
here like X so we have sigmoid of Z of X
times betas
so Sigma Z X betas and that's exactly
what we see here so you know like our
cost is some function of our output you
our hypothesis which makes a lot of
sense you know we want our hypothesis to
be as close as possible to the true
values so our cost is going to be some
function of like how much are we
different by some function of this this
hypothesis so our cost here is kind of
1/2 Y hat minus y squared and if we you
know go back to sin PI for a minute if
we go back to sin PI for a minute you
know if if we have you know 1/2 times
you know something squared here here
we'll use Q again 1/2 times something
squared you know that's that's a
parabola that's a it's a good ol you
know convex function this is a this is a
parabola and here this is kind of change
of variable so this Q is really like Y
hat minus y and this this little example
but that's okay you know we can we can
use change your variable and call that Q
and that doesn't change anything so if
we look at the derivative of this you
know we get a straight line and if we if
we kind of see what that means without
kind of suppressing the output we get 1
times Q so basically when we had
one-half Q squared here we get 1 times Q
that may not be a surprise to some folks
but it means that you know somewhere in
the output you know somewhere when we do
this chain rule calculation we take the
derivative of C with respect to Sigma
then take the derivative of Sigma with
respect to Z then take the derivative of
Z with reflected W because ultimately we
want to do is get this information to W
to the gradient you're through the
gradient to W to these weights so we
have to kind of keep taking the
derivative until we get to W and you
know the fact that we expect to see you
you know Y hat minus y that should give
us a lot of you know confidence in this
right so like here we have one of the
three terms we were using to compute
this gradient you know we have this
thing this thing and you know layer two
minus y which is y hat minus y so those
are kind of the three mystery terms from
calculus we're trying to account for
with the training rule and if we take
that kind of threw we'll take the
derivative kind of in the in the mention
I in the in the the form I mentioned
kind of property
through the the functions the
quote-unquote chain and we see we get Y
hat minus y times sigmoid prime of Z you
know Z is again a function of X and W a
function of our you know our layer of
the input to the layer and the weights
and we also get X because that's you
know when we take the derivative of you
know a constant times X you will just or
you know add W times some constant here
X when we take the derivative of X W
with respect to W we'll just get X so
those are our kind of the three terms
we're trying to account for and sure
enough you know this thing you know
layer 0 transposed that's really just X
you know and you know for each layer we
can call the input X here so this is X
this is sigmoid prime of Z right we
haven't even reduced it you know we
haven't done any reduction of that it's
just Sigma prime of Z and here we have
you know the layer two minus y so the
three terms that kind of magically
appeared here are actually from the
chain rule so that's that's kind of
where this comes from and when people
say chain rule back propagation what
they mean is kind of this step you know
this sequence of kind of mini calculus
steps to figure out kind of what these
what these you know what form they
should take on and I will say we're
being a little fast and loose with you
know sig Prime this only works because
we've already passed
you know layer two through through you
know a sigmoid function but that's okay
that's always going to be the case for
what we're doing so the fact that we
have kind of a slightly incorrect
definition actually aligns perfectly
with what we need to do so alright so
this is looking good you know this
clearly did the right thing and we now
are somewhat more confident that kind of
the the actual math we laid out is
correct I would say we're gonna make no
attempt to justify this term this term
is actually if we just did the chain
rule two more times we would see this
term which is kind of how we get the
loss for interior layers for hidden
layers but it's just really it's just
two more steps of the chain rule so
that's great but like how do we
generalize this so
this worked but the you know the for
loop is probably not the optimal way to
do deep learning so so how can we how
can we generalize this you know one
thing we can do is we can have some
kinds of functions so you know here here
we are some kinds of layers that encode
information about functions so here if
we have some you know some edom some
Python enum where we expect a function
in a function prime you know we can see
you know sigmoid we know how to do this
one right so we have sick and sick prime
but you know we could have another
function maybe the tan h function
hyperbolic tangent function which is in
dumb PI and the derivative again being a
little fast and loose with the
derivative looks like that so what is
this teenage thing so we can go back to
sin PI and sin PI also has ten H and we
can we can plot that and we see that
Tanis looks a lot like sigmoid the
difference though is it goes between
negative 1 and 1
so that will be important in the future
so so whereas you know the sigmoid
function we built earlier goes from 0 to
1 this tnh function kind of looks like a
you know a thinner version of sigmoid
and goes from negative 1 to 1 so that's
another activation function that we may
be able to use in an ER all that so we
have these kinds of layers but now we
actually need a layer so you know we
need some layer class that encodes this
information and one of those things you
know probably the most important thing
this layer class has to do is it needs
to know how to go backwards
that's the backward pass that we defined
in kind of the for loop neural net it
needs to be able to do the gradient
updating so what it takes is you know
someone tells me the loss of me my layer
you know this layer that's that's just
some tensor of some kind and I want to
output a tensor that's kind of V the
loss of the next layer so I need to
follow this contract you know someone
tells me my loss and then I need an
output you know the loss of the probe
layer to kind of like obey this contract
so that means you know we need to get
the probe layer loss but before we do
that you know this is the betas update
we were doing so we had these betas and
we we want some learning rate here it'll
be fixed and we'll subtract off the grad
you know the gradient but for that we
need to figure out what the gradient is
and for that we need
to know kind of what we were calling the
delta before here I call that error
signal sorry for the the change of name
but it's this is the Delta from the for
loop so you know the error signal is
kind of exactly the same as it was
before so it's this layer loss but now
now we need to like actually do some
initialization for this thing so we
don't have all the information we need
yet so like if we have an initialization
what are the things we need well someone
needs to tell us the kind of this layer
so someone tells us the kind and the
sheet of this layer you know what is my
shape and what I need to do with that
information is you know I need to figure
out what my function is so the kind has
this function and I also need to know
kind of what the derivative of my
function is you know my activation is
and then I need betas right so I need
these betas and that'll be the same as
before so we have these betas and with
that you know we can it we can actually
look at what the forward pass will be is
so again we had this forward pass
followed by this backward pass and in
the forward pass you know we kind of
took in some input another tensor and
returned the tensor and okay so so what
did we do
so one thing we need to do is store
store the input someone gives us so
someone tells me you know the input of
mine or all that or up the layer to this
neural net and I need to keep that and
then I need to do this you know
activated you know this is my layer
passed through the non-linearity before
it was sigmoid so we're doing sigmoid x
no Z of X B right so this is you know my
function my input and you know my betas
and then we return that you know we
return self dot activated and the reason
that we needed to do this like storing
is if we go back to our for loop you
know in the forward pass of the neural
network we define you know things like
layers your on layer one but we actually
use those information in
backward pass so there's information
that we discover in the forward pass
that actually gets used in the backward
pass which means that when we're doing
this I kind of like layer abstraction to
make our neural net more general we have
to keep this information from the
forward pass so we can apply it in the
backward pass okay so we have this
information you know we've saved the
input and the activated during the
forward pass and how do we use them so
the error signal is just as it was
before we had this loss and you know we
had this function prime before it was
sigmoid Prime and we had our self
activated right so we had you know self
dot activated and then the Grad was you
know our input transposed times you know
this error signal and the probe layer
loss was this error signal
you know matrix multiplied with you know
our betas transposed so that's what
that's what we were doing before in the
for loop and hopefully the strategy will
also generalize so just to look at kind
of like what are the the dimensions of
these like using the dimensions of
matrices is often a valuable way to to
figure out like kind of what's going on
so you know this error signal this thing
is like M by K so say we have M rows and
we're in an M by K layer so we're a
layer that has like K hidden neurons and
we're trying to kind of do this you know
back propagation of the gradient for my
layer where I'm an M by K layer so the
error signal is M by K just like the
layer you know so like the layer itself
is M by K and the error signal is M by K
which is great the loss is M by K you
know all of these line up but the
gradient write the gradient needs to
have the dimensions of my betas because
I'm using I'm kind of subtracting it
from the betas so the betas are N by K
and that is because you know the the
prior layer was M by n so to connect
this M by n layer to an M by K layer I
need an N by K kind of like n by K betas
and that means the gradient better be n
by K 2 and so the input transposed this
input transposed is n by M and the error
signal is M by K so when we do the
matrix multiplication
we'll get n by K just in keeping with
the betas
so that's looking very promising okay
so now what you know if we want to have
some neural net you know that kind of is
scikit-learn style so this is you know
this is base estimator from socket
learned you know this is really this is
a you know thin wrapper around layer you
know really we want layer to do all the
work in particular the bargain we're
gonna we're going to strive for here is
we want every single method in this
neural net to be one line you know one
line of implementation all of the work
should have been done for us already by
the layer class we just find so what we
take is a list of layers and you know we
can store that and that's good so so we
have a list of these these you know
layer fellows and that's all we take is
analyzation and now our forward we take
some X right someone gives us that the X
data you know the the design matrix and
what do we do with it well we're gonna
return X pipe through some functions so
what is pipe so pipe is just a utility
pipe is just saying if I have some data
and I have three functions this is
equivalent to you know calling all three
functions on the data in succession and
the reason this is useful is just to
make it easier to apply multiple
functions in a row which we're going to
need to do because our neural network
has multiple layers so it's just a
utility and great so what do we need
well we need to go forward and we have
all these layers so we're done you know
we just delegate to the layers they go
forward and you know we're in good shape
so backward so someone tells us the last
layer loss you know someone tells us
like when we computed the layer loss of
the final layer that was kind of our
hypothesis which is layer two minus y so
that was the the last layers output and
that's always easy it's always easy to
get the last layers output because we
know what we want you know we know we're
like spitting out of our network and we
know what the true answer is during
during training so it's really easy to
get the loss of the last layer so
someone tells me the loss
the last layer and what do I do
well you can probably see where this is
going but I take the last layer loss and
well I've got these layers so I can go
backward but I want to go backward you
know backward so I actually want self
soft out layers reversed because I need
to start at the end and go you know
towards the beginning okay cool so now
we need a fit this is like our training
step so we take X again we're just
tensor and Y which is tensor and we
return you know our self we return under
all that and that means we need to
return self but before that this is just
our for loop so we have this for loop
and what do we need again we need to go
backwards so this is kind of this is
this backwards is how we update the
gradients so every time we call backward
in some layer it's updating the beta's
using the grad so that's what we want to
have happen so we need to go backwards
and we need a hypothesis and how do we
get a hypothesis well that's just self
forward X so this is this will get us
the output of the very last layer so to
get the loss that's just you know cell
tower forward - why
and then we return self but and this
kind of silly but we were promised
one-line you know we were promised one
line per method so we're gonna get that
so you know one thing we can do is and
this is this is a silly trick but we can
return any of that or self and so what
this does is you know any as a function
that takes a list and it returns you
know whether any of them were truthy and
so backward you know backward always
returns none so we're gonna go backwards
you know 60,000 times we're gonna have a
list of you know 60,000 nuns and false
or something you know false or anything
is anything so we're gonna always get
false and then return self and this is a
silly trick but hey that's a lot of
coding what do you want so we have a fit
method now
but we actually you know the reason we
made this neural net is because we want
to make predictions and basically we
want to take a tensor ax and return a
tensor which is our hypothesis but we
needed one more thing so if we think
back to the neural you know the the
neural net at the very beginning which
was a for loop what came out of that
neural net was not zeros and ones
it was probabilities there was a
probability really close to zero that
the positive class would be one you know
if we wanted to signal a zero in this
you know binary classification problem
and it was a probability really near one
if we wanted to signal that you know the
known that was highly highly confident
that the output for that row should be
one so that means this forward method it
really returns probabilities so pretty
prob a you know this is this is a method
that's I could learn you know estimators
may have you know if you look at the
logistic regression classifier for
example you'll see this predicts prob a
method it predicting probabilities and
that's really just the forward method
here you know you know toy example you
know this is a toy example you know
binary classification but you know in
this setting you know predict prob a is
just forward so you know with that you
know we can return you know X piped
through pipe again through you know
predict prob a then we need to round
those predictions so we want the
predictions to not be near zero or near
one we want them to actually be zero or
one and then we want them to be integers
not floats that's not super important so
if we try to clean this up a little bit
now we see we do have these we have
these six methods we actually only have
five lines of implementation you know
for these for these six methods because
we got one for free so we have messed up
something here which is to be expected
but but really this this known that is
not doing a whole lot we have very very
very terse methods and that's because
you know kind of everything is being
done everything is being done by the
layers so this
is kind of the promise of neural nets in
some ways is that they're very
composable I have a lair it does cool
things I can make that play nice with
every other kind of lair
I can imagine so all of the all of the
actual work is is done by the layers and
then neural net is just a wrapper that
kind of coordinates things so this makes
it very easy to kind of change things
like the activation function you know
make other you know changes in the size
of the layers etc the number of layers
because really each layer is you know
self encapsulating and are really a
really powerful way so great does this
thing work you know live coding at all
so hopefully so what we need is to give
this thing layers and we know how to go
make a couple kinds of layers will start
with sigmoid that's what we were doing
earlier so kind is you know sigmoid and
the shape well before we had this kind
of like 3e4 and we had you know for one
so we'll try it you know we'll try it
and sure enough right like Y hat equals
y so not bad so so this this little
neuron that you know with all of five
lines of implementation is getting the
correct answer and again that's that's
thanks not to not to anything here not
anything you know on this screen but
thanks to layer so kind of an alternate
title to this talk is you know the
mighty layer class because really this
this layer class is it's quite mighty
you know all of the work all of the work
of the neural net is encapsulated in
this layer so we're not quite out of the
woods that's because you know we this
tan age function does this thing work
you know so far so good but what happens
if I put tan age here right like there's
not gonna end well for me great so I got
all ones hmm so so what's the problem
so the problem if we go back to tan age
and go back to sin pi is that tan H goes
from negative 1 to 1 not 0 to 1 so the
output cannot be you know taken as a
probability
no at its face you know the output of a
zero one classification you know a
probability a floating point between
zero and one can be can be taken as a
probability but that won't work for 10h
because it goes from negative 1 to 1 not
0 to 1 so putting 10 H as one of our
interior layers is great we can do that
all day but if we're trying to do this
binary classification of 0 & 1 tan H
can't be the last layer ok so that's
good you know we have we have this just
known that it's working well not when
you know you have 10 H is the last thing
but I want to I want to take take a
minute to pitch senpai so we've been
looking at plots from some PI and you
know some PI is an unfocused project
after all and I think Tim pie is one of
the really underappreciated projects in
a kind of the scientific Python space
it's not everyday you have to deal with
calculus with derivatives with integrals
but when you're working with deep
learning you do you know sometimes maybe
not every day but depending on what
you're working on is really really
valuable to be able to have this have
this tool at your disposal to visualize
things like what is the derivative of
you know the sigmoid function look like
that's you know sort of non-trivial to
do by hand it's not it's not super hard
but it's been a while since most of us
have taken calculus so having sympathy
as really cool and I want to I want to
give an example so one of my favorite
function in one of my favorite
activation functions to come out
recently there's this thing called
swish-swish function and before I
introduce it I want to introduce the
relu function this is this kind of the
the most popular activation function
today in deep learning is this thing
called the rectified linear unit and
thanks to some PI we can see what it
looks like so we need some relu of Q you
want to plot that so what's really so
it's just this you know it's the maximum
of 0 and Q so when we plot the relative
Q it's you know it's just a straight
line at 0 in the negative domain of X
and kind of a straight line with you
know slope whatever in the positive
domain and this turns out to be a really
powerful
vision function but it's a little
annoying that it's kind of it's got this
silly discontinuity at zero and it's
it's got an interesting derivative to so
you know this may be not too surprising
but the derivative is zero kind of in
the negative domain and then one in the
positive main but there's this other
function this this really interesting
swish function that I was just talking
about which looks a lot like relu but
has some interesting properties so the
switch function is from from a Google
paper about a year ago and switch looks
like this so it's you know I think our
cue are our free variable times the
sigmoid of Q times some scaleable
parameter so that this parameter is beta
here it's 1 it looks like this it's got
this weird kind of negative region here
you know you don't see that every day
this activation function is not
monotonic you know it starts at 0 goes
down and then goes back up that's weird
you know you don't see that with sigmoid
you don't see that with 10h you know you
don't see that with relu certainly but
it's kind of cool but what's really neat
about this is you know we can take a
look at the derivative thanks to some PI
and it looks kind of like the relu
derivative right like the function looks
like relu the derivative looks kind of
like relu but you know it's it's not
perfect but we've got this parameter and
like what if we play with this parameter
so if say beta is 10 you know now all of
a sudden this looks really really like
you know if we get rid of the derivative
there we can't tell this is different
from relu you know so we have this
parameter when it's really high
the swished function looks like r lu and
when it's really low say it's zero now
it's just a linear activation so we
didn't talk about linear activations but
this is also like a very useful part of
an urn you know any any just straight
matrix multiplication is kind of a
linear activation and so we have the
swish thing you know it's a swish and it
kind of interpolates between relu and
linear you know if if you crank up the
beta parameter or I mean you can
certainly learn the radar ammeter to but
if you set a high beta parameter you get
something that looks like for all the
world like relu and
you said it really low you get something
that's just linear so it's kind of a
generalization of this linear layer and
the rel you layer in this kind of much
smoother function than the rel you so
well there's nothing like particularly
switch has turned out to be very very
powerful
that's probably underused right now but
there's nothing that important to take
away with swish what's important to take
away with is you know simp I is really
cool you know if you're working with
deep learning you probably have to deal
with derivatives you probably have to do
with integrals you should give some piyo
shot because it it really simplifies
these things so with that I'd like to
thank you for your time and open up the
floor for any questions there may be
mics maybe
remember
I'm also able to repeat questions if I
can hear them my apologies I missed the
first two minutes of your talk I was
obviously late can I just ask a question
about did you in fact just summarize
pretty much all of deep learning with
just numpy and nothing else
all of deep learning might be might be a
stretch but this was our imports so we
we the only import of import was numb by
but we are certainly missing a lot of
things you know where we're missing
convolutions although those are easy to
write and on pie we're missing recurrent
neural nets although those are easy to
write and on pie but but really that's
kind of what these libraries like PI
torch and tensorflow are there really
just numb by you know their their numpy
and then some functions that are
wrapping numpy like stuff so deep
learning is is mostly just matrix
algebra and matrix calculus so in a
sense yes in a sense that's that's what
we're aiming for
sweet well thank you all again
[Applause]
[Music]